ihr kampfgeist ist ungebrochen die moral
der ukraine
kampfpiloten der ukrainischen armee
kehren von einem einsatz heimfliegen
mehrfach über eine leere autobahn und
wollen zeigen wir sind wieder da
unversehrt
am boden eine junge frau die mit der
blau gelben flagge winkt
das ukrainische verteidigungsministerium
teilt diese aufnahmen über seine
sozialen netzwerke bild militärexperten
ordnen diese als echt uns aktuell 1
wo genau die jets über die autobahn
donnern unklar emotionale und
spektakuläre bilder die ihre wirkung
nicht verfehlen und zeigen sollen die
moral bei den ukrainischen soldaten uns
bei den menschen im land ist nach wie
vor intakt und die bereitschaft
ungebrochen sich gegen die russische
aggression gegen putins soldaten uns
gegen den krieg im eigenen land zur wehr
zu setzen
[Applaus]